تشارلي
تشاسين ومايكل مالون هما شبيهان بالجنود
الذين ظهروا مع آخرين في
مقال في نيويورك تايمز
وانضموا إلي الليلة إلى جانب الدكتور مانيل
إستيلار وهو مدير معهد جوزيف
كوريا لأبحاث اللوكيميا في
برشلونة إسبانيا أو بارت دي لونا إذا كنت
أريد أن أقول ذلك بهذه الطريقة أه هو
أيضًا مؤلف مشارك للدراسة حول
doppelgangers ، من الجيد أن تكون في الاستوديو ،
شكرًا يا رفاق على انضمامك إلينا تشارلي ،
سأبدأ معك ،
فأنت لست توأمًا لست قريبًا منك  كيف يبدو
أن يكون لديك شبيه
هو أنك تعلم أنه أمر مثير للاهتمام حقًا
لأننا نعلم أننا عرفنا بعضنا
البعض منذ وقت طويل يا مايكل وأنا
أعود إلى الوراء وكل ذلك كان
مصدرًا للكثير من المرح بالنسبة لنا لأنه
على مدار  سنوات كنا مخطئين بالنسبة
لبعضنا البعض في كل مكان في جميع أنحاء
أتلانتا وكانت هناك بعض
المواقف المثيرة للاهتمام التي
ظهرت لمجرد أن الناس اعتقدوا أننا
الشخص الآخر ، لذلك كان الأمر بالنسبة
لنا كثيرًا  المرح بطريقة أخرى
لأننا بالفعل أصدقاء حميمين طريقة أخرى
بالنسبة لنا حتى تعرف أن تكون حتى تعرف
أصدقاء أفضل وللتواصل أكثر
لدينا هذا الشيء بيننا الذي لم يفعله
أي شخص آخر ، فأنا أعني أن كل شخص
لديه شبيه على الأرجح ولكن  نحن في الواقع
نعرف بعضنا البعض ونعرف بعضنا البعض جيدًا ،
نعم لدي واحدة أيضًا ، أعني أن الناس يتصلون
بي أندرسون كوبر طوال الوقت
عندما يرونني في الشارع ،
أرى تشابه
مايكل
كيف تقابلتم في الواقع
عندما نقرت على هذا يا رفاق  تبدو متشابهة
لقد التقينا أه لأن أه
تشارلي انضم إلى فرقة واه كان
يعزف على الجيتار لفرقة وبدأت
الضيف مع هذه الفرقة
وأه بدأنا لأن الدوائر الاجتماعية
كانت تتقارب مع بعضها البعض
فقط أصبحنا أصدقاء لم نكن  رأينا ذلك في
بعضنا البعض
وقد أحببنا بعضنا البعض كأصدقاء
وأنت تعلم أن الصداقة نمت حتى
أه ثم بدأ الناس يشيرون
إلينا ،
أنتم يا
رفاق تشبهون الأخوة ، في الواقع ، قابلت مجموعة
من  الأصدقاء هنا في أتلانتا منذ سنوات
ولأنهم سألوني
هل تعزف الجيتار مع قرد واحد
قلت
لا ولكن صديقي تشارلي يفعل
ذلك لأنك تعلم أننا
جمعتنا الموسيقى أو الدوائر الاجتماعية وكان
الأمر رائعًا منذ
ذلك الحين  سؤال للأطباء ، أنا سعيد جدًا
لأنهم هنا يخبروننا المزيد عن
الدراسة لأنك قررت دراسة
الأشخاص الذين يشبهون نوعًا ما بشكل
صحيح والذين ليسوا قريبين منك ، فقد قمت بتجنيد 32
شخصًا شاركوا في مشروع تصوير
بواسطة الكندي
فنان كندي
أخذوا بعض الحمض النووي وأجروا اختبارات الحمض النووي
واستخدموا برامج التعرف على الوجه ،
فماذا اكتشفت بعد أن فعلت
كل ذلك حتى ننظر إلى هؤلاء
الأشخاص وهم يتشاركون نفس الوجوه في الواقع
في المرة الأولى التي أراهم فيها  الجسم الحي حقًا
في الواقع
ومن هؤلاء الأشخاص ، أخذنا للتو
مادة بيولوجية وقمنا بتحليل الحمض
النووي وفي هذا الحمض النووي يمكننا أن نرى أن
هؤلاء يشبهون البشر في الواقع ، فهم
يشاركون العديد من المتغيرات الجينية
وهذه خمسة  هم مشتركون بينهم لذا فهم
يشتركون في هذه المتغيرات الجينية
التي ترتبط بطريقة أن
لديهم شكل الأنف
والعين والفم والشفتين وحتى بنية العظام
، وكان هذا هو
الاستنتاج الرئيسي الذي يجمعهم الوراثة
معًا وعوامل أخرى
مختلفون وهذا هو السبب في أنهم ليسوا
متطابقين تمامًا ، ولكن هذا
لأنهم يمتلكون حمضًا نوويًا مشابهًا بشكل صحيح ولكن هذا
لا يعني أنهما مرتبطان
كلاهما ليس في الحقيقة في كل حالة
عدنا أه  منذ ما يقرب من 100 عام ولم
يكن هناك أصل مشترك ، فهم غير
مرتبطين على الإطلاق ، لذا فإن
الرموز المتشابهة نعم صحيح ولكن ليس
الرموز المماثلة فقط عن طريق الصدفة العشوائية في
العالم في الوقت الحالي ، هناك الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين في نهاية المطاف ينتج النظام
البشر مع  تسلسلات الحمض النووي المتشابهة
وهذا هو السبب والآن مع
الإنترنت يمكنك العثور على كل هذا المظهر
المتشابه في العالم
بطريقة أسهل